[Music]
hello and welcome to the view from 22
I'm Ben Lazarus The Spectator special
projects editor after a week in which
we've seen a seasar and Gaza and a
prisoner hostage swap between the
Israelis and the Palestinians I'm joined
by ABI zacharov the writer of the hit TV
show fer to discuss the ongoing conflict
how damaging do you think the Ceasar has
been in terms of the Israeli operation
in
Gaza well it was a halt let's say and
this is the sixth day or the seventh day
and it's a kind of a problem for the ID
but it's not a big problem let's put it
that way I know from my sources that yes
it's a Slowdown in the Israeli operation
in the moving forward and taking over an
area after an area neighborhood after a
neighborhood in North Gaza at least um
but this is a price that we had to pay
in order to see those kids and the women
back back home in Israel so it was a
kind of a price that Israel was willing
to pay in order to
see the the kids and the the moms going
back home and the old ladies of course
all of them um and then yes we will see
the renew of the
fighting uh maybe Saturday maybe Sunday
but I do not really doubt that we we
will witness their
the the renew of the war um what does
the next stage of the conflict look like
I mean there's lots of reports about the
Israelis planning to go south to Target
the hamus leadership there there's been
some sort of briefing from the American
side of things saying that the um
operation can't look like what it did in
the north when it comes to the South how
do you see it necessarily playing out
when the IDF goes
south I think that we're going to see
more of the same like what we had seen
in the North we're going to see also in
kanun area um especially kanun because
it's the stronghold of Hamas because
it's
the you know the the the house or the
home of hamas's leadership especially
the refugee camp in in
kanun
and the leader of Hamas Muhammad de the
head of the military Wing they were both
born in hunus refugee camp soal and the
brother of Muhammad s was also one of
the prominent leaders in hamas's
military wing and they they built a huge
infrastructures of tunnels and Bonkers
underneath kanun city underneath kanun
refugee camp and the Israeli Army wants
to get there and he he will it will get
there and before it gets there how much
more fighting do you think is left to be
done in the
north um I think that we will see the
renew of the fighting some of the areas
that the IDF already took over because
of this s fire because it gave the Hamas
the option to send some troops over to
the north by the tunnels or by other
means and they will try to renew that
they're fighting over there and to show
that they did not surrender and they did
not really gave up the control over
those neighborhoods and adding to that
of course you have two big very big
areas in the northern G strip which are
jabalia and Sh that weren't taken by the
IDF and I'm sure that the IDF will renew
its attack in those specific
areas we we've seen this week um the
release of of many hostages and
obviously these are the hostages that
Hamas is happy to show the world um what
sort of conditions do you think um the
other hostages who aren't being released
namely the soldiers might being be being
kept
in I'm sure that they are being held in
not so good conditions um we know that
you know some of the prisoners that were
released this week meaning the women and
the kids were suffering from
U not starvation but lack of food lack
of food with a very bad medical
treatment and I'm sure that many of
those
soldiers or men that are there in
captivity are suffering from worse
conditions and a bad treatment we know
that some of the kids some of even the
foreign Thai workers that were kidnapped
into Gaza was suffering from beating
from psychological torturing from
yelling from again violence some
violence against kids against kids that
were crying at night like 12 years old
11 years old so I'm sure that the
soldiers are facing even way way more
severe conditions
and what do you make of reports that one
of the hostages was kept in the Attic of
a house belonging to a un
worker I don't know about that I don't
know to confirm it yes or no but
listen the situation in Gaza right now
is
that many of the houses many of the
families that are there in Gaza are very
proas that's not something that I
invented this is not such a kind of of a
secret we know that Hamas is very
popular in Gaza Strip we know that many
of the people in Gaza are working for
Hamas whether for the military Wing
which is around 40 to 50,000 people or
for hamas's government hamas's police
Etc that brings us to a huge number of
people that are being financed by Hamas
and we didn't get to the tunnels for for
example tunnels were built since 2007
since hamas's Coupe and just as a
reminder Hamas took over Gaza in a very
violent Coupe against the PA against the
paltin in fat killed 160 Palestinians in
order to take over the Gaza stream since
then they've been building a huge
network of tunnels using thousands of
people that this is how they were making
a living to dig those tunnels underneath
Gaza we're not talking about a small
tunnel in the dark here that you need to
crawl these are big tunnels that
sometimes you can walk sometimes you can
ride a motorbike and sometimes you can
drive a car underneath Gaza Strip so
this is a tunnel just like you seen
Western cities that you can drive safely
with a car from a place to
place and am I right in thinking that
you spent time in in Gaza with the Hamas
leadership
before I did I was there till 2007 and
since 2007 I was not allowed from the
Israeli side they didn't allow me to go
into daa
anymore and how did you find the Hamas
leadership could you have ever imagined
that they would be capable of um doing
what they did on October the 7th look I
knew that they were you know the leaders
of a terrorist organization we knew that
they do not really fund of Israelis or
Jews in general but there was a kind of
a status quo a kind of an understanding
that you know at the end of the day we
will need to leave with them although we
don't like them meaning the
Israelis uh I remember myself being in
mahar's house one of the leaders of the
political wing and that was at December
2005 just before the elections for the
Parliament and he said if we will win
the elections for the parliament we will
do some kind of a a commercial agreement
some kind of an agreement with the
Israel is that will allow us to live
meaning around electricity and water and
sewage Etc so we'll be able to stay in
Gaza as a kind of a normal territory or
normal place to live
in since then something had changed in
Kamas we found out about that only on
October 7th we thought that they were
logical people that you can negotiate
with maybe you know offering them some
kind of economic Prosperity 18,000 500
people Palestinians were going out from
Gaza into Israel every day to work in
Israel I had people just here outside my
house in Tel Aviv from Gaza from Rafa in
the southern edge of Gaza Strip that
were working here in Tel Aviv but all
the attempts from the Israeli side you
know to offer them some kind of economic
Prosperity didn't really work and at the
end they pulled this terrible war and
they forced Israelis and Palestinians to
be drawn into this terrible War how
worried are you about the West Bank I
mean there's been quite a lot of
simmering tension since the 7th of
October I I know you've served in in the
West Bank yourself um do you see things
getting much worse
there I'm not sure that it's going to
get so much worse I think that at the
end we will see you know more attempts
just like we'd seen uh in the last 24
hours that uh some terrorists came to
the entrance to Jerusalem and shooting
like crazy and we might see more of that
more attempts but I don't I do not see a
large scale escalation in the West Bank
mainly because of the Palestinian
Authority that is not interested in that
and it's trying to do whatever it's
possible in order to prevent it from
taking
place um as an Israeli um what do you
make of the response in in the west I
don't know how closely you may or may
not have followed um the reaction in the
west but are you quite disappointed that
that the response has not been
overwhelmingly uh on your
side you know I don't know if I'm
surprised that's the would yes I am
disappointed to see that I did think
that you know when I had this argument
with a good friend of mine from that
said that now the whole world is with
Israel and I said it's going to ask for
like 48 hours maybe 72 hours and then
again people will start attacking us for
retaliating which is an absurd and
honestly I stopped waiting for anyone in
the west or in Europe especially or in
the UK to be supportive of the St of
Israel and just like this movie frankly
my dear I don't give a damn I really
don't give a damn anymore I know that
Israel needs to do whatever it needs to
do in order to keep its citizens safe
period simple as that and if that means
to take this Gaza STP and to go for a
war that would last for months and
months and to create such a damage that
the Palestinians would bear in mind for
the next 100 years yes we need to do
that and we will do that and what would
your preferred outcome of the war be
would you like to see the Gaza Strip
control by the PA or um occupied by
Israel or would you like to see sort of
an international peacekeeping body
oversee the whole
thing I think you know the fantasy would
be some kind of an
international body organization a few
countries that will take over Gaza and
manage it but this is a fantasy this is
a a dream that will not come true I
don't see any volunteers waiting in line
to take over the responsibility of uh
the Gaza Strip I know that the Arab
countries like Egypt and the others are
totally not interested in managing Gaza
in
future the Palestinian Authority is very
weak it's very corrupt and it doesn't
have any kind of a political Horizon
since the government of Israel doesn't
want to show it any kind of a political
Horizon so I'm not sure that they are
even relevant as a kind of an option in
Gaza I think that at the end the less
Wars scenario will be that the Israeli
government will get to some kind of an
understanding and agreement with the pa
the personing authority will help her
will help it to get stronger and will
allow it to manage the issues of Gaza
think that reoccupying Gaza Strip it's a
mistake we don't need that we don't want
that I think that what we do know for
sure is that we need to bring down
Hamas and if n he was to strike a deal
with the Palestinian Authority um would
he be able to politically survive that I
mean would that be something he could
actually
do the answer is very
long
no simple as that he won't survive it
his Coalition is a full right-
Wingers and they will not even allow him
to move one million meter towards the
Palestinian Authority or Mahmud Abbas
the president definitely not getting
into any kind of an agreement political
agreement with them or withdrawing from
a territory here or withdrawing from a
settlement over there it's not on the
table it will be the end of his
government but again I'm not that sure
that this government the Israeli
government will
survive after the war I think that the
last day of the war will will also be
the last day of this government
all right well look ay thank you thank
you so much for for taking the time to
to talk to me today thank you very much
[Music]
man